tout le monde est d'accord personne vous
n'allez pas de sortir une chute qui
n'existe pas les enfants ne risquent
rien de cette maladie là une fois qu'on
a attrapé la maladie on ne leur fait pas
sur les millions de corps de kovy de
déclarer à l'om est ce qu'il ya eu trois
corps je crois de gens qui auront qu'on
leur a chuté après un qu'ovide naturel
donc on a une immunité qui est certaine
à deux ils demandent à 15 ans de recul
pour l'instant puisque l épidémie
n'existait pas avant
je vous disais un truc comme si les
enfants s'étaient tous contaminés
ouais je dis ce serait vraiment un grand
bonheur parce que les effectifs ont ils
font le barrage à la maladie dans le
futur je veux dire est ce qu'il m'a dit
un truc intéressant pendant la pause ici
il me disait le lac au vide est le
révélateur de l'état de santé de
certaines personnes comme vous ça veut
dire quoi
ça veut dire que l'on meurt du coc vite
quand on devait mourir la durée de vie
moyenne en france est de 84 ans la durée
moyenne de des morts de communes et 85
ans on n'y a pas pandémie en fait j'ai
jamais dit ça est que j'aidais naturel
en fait non j'ai dit que c'est cette
pandémie il ya beaucoup de virus qui
circule ni à une vraie maladie
cette maladie tue les gens qui sont
fragiles et les voyages naturel web
basso qui sont des brouillages nettoyage
naturel pardonnez moi mais je serai
remettent absolument oui elle voudrait
dire que donc et des gens c'est naturel
on s'en fiche il en est destiné à leur
conscience que la balaye la ville se
termine par la mort quoi qu'on fasse
ces deux erreurs c'est ça la réalité
c'est dire sa fixiez monsieur est ce
qu'on doit mourir asphyxié à 85 85 ans à
vous en train de dire ça nettoyage mais
vous êtes un danger public non en plus
vous parlez de choses que vous ne
maîtrisez pas vous êtes face à un
médecin non mais reprenons là et
embellissent à ce que les gens ils sont
complètement perdus
moi je vais vous dire j'ai un cash et
moi ne pas pas et j'en ai parlé il est
unique et dialysés je vais vous dire un
truc pour protéger mon père il faut que
moi elle me faire vacciner aussi parce
que c'est pourquoi là je rappelle à tous
mais c'est aussi pas le signer si la
solution mais je suis désolé vous ne
pourrez récession est d'ailleurs âge il
ya beaucoup de gens qui ralliait sur ce
que vous avez dit il veut tenir les gens
n'ont jamais lu les gens c'est
totalement différent alors je lui avais
comme la grippe est insupportable ce que
vous dites c'est à dire quasiment bravo
le virus il va les gérer a dit ça c'est
ce qu'on entend non c'est comme une
guerre il va y avoir des sacrifiés dans
génération bio on au vieux nos
personnages et peut mourir mais c'est
pas grave il serait mort il jamais si
c'est ce que vous dites monsieur non
mais si j'ai dit que la maladie aussi le
mérite de mourir
monsieur despinoy je pense oui
les salaires moyens ya plein de gens qui
ont des primaires qui ont mon grand-père
me 82 85 ans pour eux ils voient pas
leurs actes ils ont juste envie de dire
oui et moment encore de bonheur avec
leurs grands pères ou leurs grands mères
l'aco vide est passée par là et ça a
accéléré
mine de rien le remords je suis désolé
c'est pas des gens qui devaient moyens
on l'a tout de suite et ça accélérer
accélérer leur mort donc on voulait de
85 ans que vous avez un grand père que
vous aimez une grand mère que vous
adorez chaque jour de gagné ainsi si
cela est là le lac au vide on va pas
dire que ça c'est mine de rien ça ça
accélère donc c'est pas des gens qui
devait mourir en raison des calculs très
précis qui ont été faits sur ce problème
combien d'années d'années perdues par le
vide et on se rend compte que le coc
vide a depuis
ap fait perdre très peu d'années de vie
c'est faux nous faire du gras mais parce
que vous convenez deux choses
l'espérance de vie à la naissance
on va dire 85 ans et l'espérance de vie
une fois que vous
avait atteint ses 85 ans c'est à dire
qu'une fois que vous êtes arrivé à 85
ans dont les noms étaient alignés asile
mais ont tenu compte de ça fout ils ont
dit at-elle âge on attelle et ils ont
perdu dix ans d'espérance de vie mon
genre de 68 cents à 91 c'est surtout
perdu de 10 ans d'espérance aussi une
sélection naturelle etc du nettoyage
nantes médecin c'est ça c'est ça vous
avez consacré votre vie à dire aux gens
m'a finalement si vous mourez sens et
c'est la juridiction ces nettoyages
attendait parce que c'est pas digne du
de la fonction de docteur non non je
suis désolé
d'abord je n'ai pas dis ça je dis que
simplement
cette maladie touche les gens très âgés
à forte qu'au père mort militez vous ai
fait un tour dans les services de rennes
- sur wii le ministre a dit attention
les jeunes sont touchés
qu'est ce qui s'est passé on est passé
de 67 ans à 63 ans dans la moitié est
très jeune et donc dise pas que c'est
des gens jeunes là